Bonjour à tous,
aujourd'hui ensemble, nous allons visiter
un endroit exceptionnel.
Ici, au CERN, à Genève, se trouve
une des machines
les plus extraordinaires jamais construites
par l'être humain: le LHC.
Le LHC c'est le plus grand et le plus puissant
accélérateur de particules au monde,
vous le savez peut-être il a notamment
été conçu dans le but
de débusquer le fameux boson de Higgs.
Une entreprise couronnée de succès
puisque cette découverte a été annoncée
ici même au CERN, le 4 juillet 2012.
Ensemble aujourd'hui nous allons explorer
le LHC en essayant de comprendre
les incroyables défis scientifiques
et technologiques
qu'il a fallu relever pour mettre la main
sur cette particule insaisissable.
[Générique]
Le boson de Higgs, vous vous êtes peut-être
déjà demandé
pour quelle raison on parle autant
de cette particule
et pourquoi elle fascine à ce point
les physiciens.
Eh bien c'est parce qu'elle représente
la toute dernière pièce d'un grand
puzzle scientifique
dont la résolution aura duré
presque un demi-siècle.
Entre les années 1950 et 1960 de nombreux
physiciens ont travaillé
à bâtir une grande théorie
censée expliquer
toute la structure fondamentale
de la matière, on appelle cette théorie
le "modèle standard de la physique
des particules".
Ce modèle fait appel à 16 types
de particules élémentaires
qui permettent d'expliquer la totalité
des formes de matière
et l'ensemble de ses interactions
dans le monde de l'infiniment petit.
Mais pour tenir debout cette théorie
ambitieuse avait besoin
d'un ingrédient supplémentaire,
une 17ème particule
ayant pour lourde tâche d'expliquer
l'existence
de la masse des autres particules
fondamentales.
Cette ultime pièce du puzzle,
c'est le fameux boson de Higgs.
Aujourd'hui je ne vais pas revenir sur
ce rôle théorique du boson de Higgs,
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le faire
dans une vidéo précédente sur le sujet.
Puisqu'on a la chance d'être au CERN,
je voudrais plutôt me concentrer
sur les formidables prouesses
qu'il a fallu accomplir
pour mettre en évidence cette particule
presque un demi-siècle après
qu'elle ait été imaginée
par François Englert, Robert Brout
et Peter Higgs.
Et pour bien comprendre pourquoi
nous avons eu besoin
d'une machine aussi extraordinaire
que le LHC
pour attraper ce boson de Higgs,
je voudrais commencer
par revenir dans le temps
pour vous expliquer
comment on s'y prend pour découvrir
de nouvelles particules.
Projetons nous presque 90 ans
en arrière, en 1932,
cette année là on vient de démontrer
l'existence du neutron
et Heisenberg propose alors
son modèle de l'atome
qui est celui que nous connaissons bien
et qu'on trouve dans les manuels scolaires.
Un atome y est représenté comme un noyau
formé de protons chargés positivement
et de neutrons,
et autour duquel on trouve des électrons
chargés négativement.
Si on ajoute à cela le photon
pour la lumière,
toute la structure de la matière
semblait alors pouvoir s'expliquer
avec l'aide de ces quatre particules.
Sauf qu'à partir de l'année 1932
on a commencé à en trouver
tout un tas d'autres.
Des particules qui nous avaient échappé
jusqu'ici, et ce pour une bonne raison:
elles n'existent pas de façon stable
à l'état naturel.
C'est par exemple le cas du muon,
un lointain cousin de l'électron,
dont la durée de vie est de seulement
2 microsecondes.
Malgré cette existence éphémère des muons
sont produits en permanence
par les collisions des rayons cosmiques
qui viennent frapper les molécules
de l'atmosphère.
Du fait de leur durée de vie si courte
les muons avaient échappé
à l’œil des physiciens de l'époque
mais dans les années 30 on a pu découvrir
leur existence
grâce à un détecteur très simple
une chambre à brouillard.
La chambre à brouillard c'est
une sorte d'aquarium
étanche et saturé de vapeur d'alcool,
quand une particule traverse la chambre,
elle laisse une traînée derrière elle
provoquée par la condensation de l'alcool
ce qui trahit sa présence
et permet ainsi de visualiser sa trajectoire.
Alors savoir qu'une particule vient de passer
c'est bien
mais encore faut-il pouvoir la caractériser
et l'identifier.
Une façon de le faire
c'est de placer la chambre à brouillard
dans un champ magnétique
on sait en effet qu'un champ magnétique
courbe les trajectoires
des particules qui possèdent une charge
c'est ainsi qu'on a pu observer
que certaines trajectoires,
dans les chambres à brouillard,
se courbaient
mais de façon bien moins prononcée
que celle des électrons,
cela a permis de comprendre qu'on avait là
des particules inconnues au bataillon,
chargées négativement comme l'électron
mais environ 200 fois plus lourdes,
ces particules qu'on a fini
par baptiser les muons.
Cette histoire de la découverte des muons
est assez ancienne
mais elle illustre bien les deux ingrédients
qui sont toujours nécessaires
lorsqu'on est à la recherche
de nouvelles particules.
D'un côté puisqu'il s'agit de particules
qui n'existent pas à l'état naturel,
il faut un moyen de les produire,
dans le cas des muons c'étaient les rayons
cosmiques qui jouaient ce rôle.
Et de l'autre, il faut pouvoir
les caractériser et les identifier
et à l'époque on utilisait donc une chambre
à brouillard avec un champ magnétique.
Depuis les années 30 l'histoire
de la physique des particules expérimentale
est allée de pair avec l'évolution
des moyens techniques
permettant de produire et détecter
de nouvelles particules.
Du côté de la création de particules,
on n'a fondamentalement besoin
que d'un seul ingrédient: de l'énergie,
et ce d'autant plus qu'on cherche à créer
des particules massives,
c'est l'un des sens de la fameuse
relation e = mc² .
On l'a dit, dans le cas des muons
cette énergie provenait
des collisions des rayons cosmiques
avec les particules de l'atmosphère,
mais pour pouvoir produire et découvrir
toujours plus de nouvelles particules,
il a fallu faire appel à des collisions
artificielles
et donc à des accélérateurs de particules.
Le principe de base en est assez simple:
on prend une particule de départ
qui possède une charge,
par exemple un électron, un proton,
et on la fait passer dans un champ
électrique pour l'accélérer.
C'est comme ça que fonctionne
le canon à électrons
qu'on retrouve notamment dans les tubes
cathodiques des vieilles télévisions.
En envoyant ensuite ces particules accélérées
entrer en collision avec un matériau,
on libère de l'énergie susceptible de donner
naissance à de nouvelles particules.
L'énergie de collision obtenue
avec un tel système
dépend de la charge de la particule
accélérée
et de la tension utilisée et donc,
pour simplifier les calculs,
les physiciens utilisent une unité
qu'on appelle l'électronvolt noté "eV",
par exemple 1000 eV c'est l'énergie
cinétique d'un électron
qui a été accéléré dans une tension
de 1000 volts,
et ce serait pareil avec un proton
d'ailleurs,
et on utilise aussi les multiples
de cette unité,
donc vous allez m'entendre parler
de kiloélectronvolts (keV) ,
mégaélectronvolts (MeV) ,
gigaélectronvolts (GeV) ,
et même téraélectronvolts (TeV) .
Une limite de cette technique
d'accélération
c'est qu'il est difficile de créer
et de maintenir une tension statique
supérieure à quelques centaines
de milliers de volts
et donc les énergies de collision
que l'on peut atteindre
dépassent difficilement, disons un MeV,
pour s'affranchir de cette limitation
il existe une solution:
s'arranger pour que les particules
qu'on accélère
reviennent passer plusieurs fois de suite
dans le même champ électrique
avant d'être libérées.
Cela nécessite de pouvoir contrôler
leur trajectoire
et on peut le faire avec un autre champ,
que j'ai déjà mentionné,
le champ magnétique.
En effet puisque le champ magnétique courbe
la trajectoire des particules chargées
on peut s'en servir pour leur faire suivre
un trajet circulaire ou en spirale.
En combinant ainsi des champs
électriques et magnétiques
on peut créer ce qu'on appelle un cyclotron
qui permet de faire passer plusieurs fois
les particules dans la tension accélératrice
et donc d'atteindre des énergies bien plus
importantes que le simple canon à électrons.
Depuis beaucoup d'innovations
ont été apportées
et de nouveaux types d'accélérateur ont été
créés, comme par exemple les synchrotrons,
les différentes améliorations
ont permis d'atteindre
des énergies de plus en plus élevées
dans les collisions
et donc de produire et de découvrir
de plus en plus de nouvelles particules.
Mais pour le boson de Higgs,
c'est une autre histoire,
il s'agit en effet d'une particule
qu'on supposait très massive
et donc nécessitant beaucoup d'énergie
et de surcroît très difficile à produire,
il a donc fallu faire appel
à de nouvelles technologies,
celles du LHC dont les premiers plans
ont été imaginés dès les années 80.
Le LHC est l'accélérateur de particules
de tous les extrêmes.
Un anneau circulaire d'une circonférence
de 27 km,
située à 175 mètres sous terre, ici
à la frontière franco-suisse
et permettant de réaliser des collisions
de protons,
à l'énergie jamais vue de
14 téraélectronvolts.
Pour obtenir cette énergie de collision
on n'utilise pas un faisceau venant
frapper une cible fixe
mais deux faisceaux tournant en sens opposés
l'un de l'autre
et que l'on fait se rencontrer à des endroits
bien choisis de leur trajectoire.
Outre des protons le LHC peut également
accélérer des noyaux de plomb,
on regroupe l'ensemble sous le terme
générique de hadrons
d'où son nom "Large Hadron Collider"
mais bien qu'on parle toujours de lui,
le LHC ne fait pas le travail tout seul,
il n'est que le dernier maillon
d'une chaîne d'accélérateurs
de plus en plus puissants dont l'objectif
est d'amener progressivement
les protons jusqu'à leur énergie maximale.
Tout commence avec une simple bouteille
d'hydrogène
dont on extrait les protons qui seront
accélérés tout au long du processus,
ceux-ci débutent leur voyage dans
un accélérateur linéaire,
puis sont transmis au booster,
qui les livrent au synchrotron,
puis au super synchrotron
avant d'être injectés progressivement
dans l'anneau du LHC.
C'est au moment de cette injection
que le flux de proton est scindé en deux
de façon à alimenter les deux faisceaux
qui composent l'anneau du LHC.
Les protons des deux faisceaux
seront alors accélérés
jusqu'à l'énergie de 7 TeV
permettant d'atteindre 14 TeV
au moment des collisions.
Pour atteindre ces énergies fantastiques
le LHC se base essentiellement
sur les mêmes principes physiques
que les autres accélérateurs.
Un champ électrique pour accélérer
les particules
et un champ magnétique pour contrôler
leur trajectoire dans l'anneau
mais tout ça d'une façon bien plus complexe
qu'un simple cyclotron.
Le champ électrique utilisé est
ce qu'on appelle
un "champ radiofréquence résonnant"
qui permet d'atteindre des accélérations
bien plus élevées
que celle d'un champ électrique statique,
ce champ est appliqué dans les cavités
radiofréquences du LHC,
on en compte 16 le long de la trajectoire,
8 par faisceau.
Ces cavités permettent en quelque sorte
de donner
"un petit coup de fouet énergétique"
aux particules qui les traversent,
cela représente quelques MeV par passage
mais, à force de tourner dans l'anneau,
l'énergie des protons passe progressivement
de 450 GeV à 7 TeV.
Mais entre ces cavités accélératrices,
les protons doivent suivre la forme
circulaire de l'anneau du LHC
et pour contrôler cette trajectoire
on a besoin d'un champ magnétique.
Les 27 kilomètres qui composent l'anneau
du LHC sont principalement formés
de structures élémentaires comme celle-ci
qu'on appelle des dipôles,
chaque dipôle mesure 15 mètres de long
et pèse 35 tonnes.
À l'intérieur deux tubes de seulement
quelques centimètres de diamètre
qui contiennent les deux faisceaux
tournant en sens opposés l'un de l'autre.
Afin d'assurer la bonne courbure
de la trajectoire
ces tubes sont le siège d'un champ
magnétique énorme,
en effet plus la vitesse des protons
est importante
plus le champ magnétique doit être élevé
pour les maintenir sur la bonne trajectoire.
Ce champ augmente donc progressivement au fur
et à mesure de l'accélération des protons
jusqu'à atteindre la valeur monstrueuse
de 8 teslas
soit cent mille fois plus que le champ
magnétique terrestre.
Pour produire ce champ magnétique colossal,
on utilise des électroaimants
que l'on distingue ici,
vous connaissez peut-être le principe
de l'électroaimant,
il s'agit d'une bobine de fil et,
plus le courant qu'on y fait circuler
est élevé,
plus le champ magnétique produit au centre
de la bobine sera important.
Pour obtenir 8 teslas avec
cette configuration,
il faut y faire circuler un courant
dont l'intensité atteint 12 000 ampères.
De telles intensités on n'en trouve
nulle part évidemment
dans nos installations électriques
domestiques,
un appareil électroménager c'est généralement
quelques ampères,
au maximum ça peut atteindre
une dizaine d'ampères
dans le cas des appareils chauffants
comme les bouilloires électriques
ou les grille-pain, qui exploitent
justement le fait
que plus l'intensité électrique est élevée
plus la chaleur dégagée sera importante.
Donc à première vue un courant électrique
de 12 000 ampères
ça devrait dégager une chaleur monstrueuse,
de quoi faire s'évaporer
le lac Léman à côté.
Heureusement il existe une solution
pour s'en sortir,
c'est d'utiliser pour les électro aimants
des fils électriques pas comme les autres,
des supraconducteurs.
Un supraconducteur c'est un matériau capable
de conduire le courant
sans aucune résistance électrique et donc
sans dégagement de chaleur ni pertes inutiles.
Il n'existe que très peu de matériaux
de ce genre,
dans le cas du LHC on utilise un alliage
de niobium et de titane,
le seul souci c'est que, comme pour tous
les matériaux de ce genre,
l'effet supraconducteur ne se manifeste
qu'à des températures extrêmement basses.
Tous les aimants du LHC sont donc refroidis
jusqu'à la température glaciale
de moins 271° Celsius,
(environ 2° au dessus du zéro absolu) .
À titre de comparaison c'est juste
un tout petit peu plus froid
que l'espace intersidéral
et pour refroidir tout le LHC on utilise
12 000 tonnes d'azote liquide
et 700 mètres cubes d'hélium super fluide,
permettant de refroidir
270 000 kilomètres de câbles
supraconducteurs.
Le LHC ce sont donc des courants électriques
extrêmes, des températures extrêmes,
des champs électromagnétiques extrêmes,
mais également un vide extrême.
En effet pour éviter que les protons qui
circulent ne viennent entrer en collision
avec les molécules de l'air ambiant,
il règne dans les tubes
une pression 10 000 milliard de fois
inférieure à la pression atmosphérique.
Ce qui en fait un des endroits les plus
vides du système solaire.
Les dipôles comme celui ci ne sont pas
les seuls briques
qui permettent de construire l'anneau du LHC,
il existe de nombreux types d'aimants
ayant chacun une fonction spécifique,
comme par exemple les quadripôles
qui permettent de focaliser le faisceau
et d'éviter sa dispersion.
Pour vous donner une idée de la précision
des réglages
et des ajustements nécessaires pour garder
le faisceau sur sa trajectoire,
sachez que les opérateurs du CERN
doivent tenir compte
des mouvements et des phases de la lune
qui dilatent très légèrement l'anneau
selon un phénomène analogue
à celui des marées.
Je me trouve maintenant dans le centre
de contrôle du CERN,
c'est d'ici que sont pilotées toutes
les installations
permettant d'accélérer les protons
jusqu'au bon niveau d'énergie
pour pouvoir procéder aux expériences
de collision.
Je vous l'ai dit, le LHC reçoit ses protons
d'un accélérateur plus petit,
le super synchrotron qui les a déjà portés
à l'énergie de 450 GeV.
Ces protons sont ensuite injectés
progressivement
pour alimenter les deux faisceaux
de l'anneau du LHC
qui les amènera à l'énergie de 7 TeV.
Le total de l'opération prenant environ
une vingtaine de minute.
Chaque faisceau se structure
de la façon suivante:
les protons sont regroupés en 2800 paquets
espacés de 7 mètres tout au long de l'anneau.
Un paquet ne mesure que quelques centimètres
de long et 1 mm de diamètre
et contient environ 100 milliards de protons.
À la fin de la phase d'accélération
les paquets de protons circulent
à une vitesse très proche
de celle de la lumière:
299 millions 792 mille 455 mètres par seconde,
là où la lumière c'est:
299 millions 792 mille 458 mètres par seconde.
L'anneau mesurant 27 km, à cette vitesse-là
ils accomplissent 11 245 tours par seconde.
Au maximum l'énergie contenue dans chaque
faisceau équivaut à 80 kilos de TNT,
il vaut donc mieux ne pas
en perdre le contrôle.
C'est une fois la phase d'accélération
terminée
que les collisions peuvent commencer.
Ces collisions entre les deux faisceaux
de protons sont réalisées
sur des points de croisement situés à des
endroits bien précis de la trajectoire
où sont placés les quatre détecteurs
dont nous parlerons tout à l'heure.
Sachant que chacun des 2800 paquets
effectue 11 245 tour par seconde
vous pouvez faire la multiplication,
cela représente 30 millions de croisements
par seconde à chaque point de rencontre.
Afin d'être certain que chaque croisement
engendre le maximum de collision
à l'entrée des détecteurs, les faisceaux
sont focalisés et concentrés
grâce à des aimants spécifiques
qui permettent de réduire
le diamètre des paquets à seulement
16 microns.
Quand les faisceaux sont bien réglés,
cela permet d'obtenir
environ 20 collisions à chaque
croisement de paquets.
Alors 20 ça peut paraître peu
puisque chaque paquet contient
100 milliards de protons,
cela signifie que quand deux paquets
se croisent
ils se passent très largement au travers
l'un de l'autre.
Et pourtant, au rythme où vont les faisceaux,
20 collisions par croisement,
cela représente 600 millions
de collisions par seconde.
Ce taux de collision est un indicateur
de performance important
qui correspond à ce qu'on appelle
la "luminosité" de l'accélérateur.
De façon générale plus la luminosité
d'un accélérateur est élevée
plus on augmentera les chances de produire
et détecter les particules qu'on cherche.
Cela va sans dire, le LHC est l'accélérateur
de particules le plus lumineux du monde,
environ 100 fois plus que
son prédécesseur le LEP
qui était en fonctionnement ici même
jusqu'en novembre 2000,
et comme nous allons le voir pour espérer
produire et détecter le boson de Higgs
il fallait cette luminosité exceptionnelle.
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que pour
produire et détecter de nouvelles particules
il suffisait d'avoir de l'énergie
en quantité suffisante
mais c'est un petit peu plus subtil que ça.
La création de nouvelles particules repose
sur des interactions
entre les particules qui collisionnent
et que l'on peut grossièrement comparer
avec des réactions chimiques.
Les physiciens figurent cela avec
des petits diagrammes
représentant les particules et appelés
diagrammes de Feynman.
Pour produire des bosons de Higgs
dans le LHC,
on compte notamment sur une réaction appelée
la "fusion de gluons".
Il s'agit du fait que deux gluons, situés
dans les protons qui collisionnent
peuvent se rencontrer, interagir et
donner un boson de Higgs.
Malheureusement les modèles théoriques
et les simulations nous permettent
d'estimer que ça ne se produit que dans
une collision sur un milliard.
Donc même avec 600 millions de collisions
par seconde, faites le calcul,
ça ne fait même pas un boson de Higgs
produit par seconde de fonctionnement,
et ça ce n'est que la moitié du chemin
car comme je lai déjà mentionné,
produire de nouvelles particules
c'est bien,
encore faut-il pouvoir les capter
et les identifier.
Et ça, c'est le travail des détecteurs
Je me trouve maintenant à presque
100 mètres sous terre
dans la caverne du détecteur CMS
que vous voyez derrière moi.
Il s'agit de l'un des quatre principaux
détecteurs
actuellement présents sur le LHC
et celui qui, avec le détecteur Atlas,
a permis la découverte du boson de Higgs.
Ce détecteur fait 21 m de long
et 15 m de diamètre,
il pèse 14 000 tonnes et sa conception
et son exploitation auront nécessité
la collaboration de plusieurs milliers
de scientifiques.
Comme vous voyez on est assez loin
de la simple chambre à brouillard
qui avait permis la découverte des muons.
La raison principale de ce gigantisme
et de toutes les technologies
qu'il a fallu employer,
c'est que le boson de Higgs est incroyablement
difficile à détecter.
Une fois créé, sa durée de vie est infime
puisqu'il se désintègre au bout de seulement
10 puissance moins 22 secondes
c'est à dire un dix millième de milliardième
de milliardième de seconde.
On ne connaît aucune méthode
qui permettrait de le détecter directement
dans ce laps de temps.
La meilleure chose qu'on puisse espérer faire
c'est une détection indirecte,
c'est-à-dire l'identifier au travers
de ses désintégrations.
Et nous allons voir que c'est comme chercher
une aiguille dans une botte de foin.
Quand une collision se produit ce sont
en effet au total
des dizaines de particules qui peuvent
être émises,
c'est ce que l'on voit représenté
sur les images de ce type,
et tout le travail d'un détecteur comme CMS
sera de reconstruire correctement
les trajectoires
et les caractéristiques de toutes
les particules créées
afin de repérer celles qui trahissent
la désintégration d'un boson de Higgs
qui aurait été produit au moment
de la collision.
Pour réaliser ce fastidieux travail
de reconstruction
et d'identification un détecteur comme CMS
est conçu avec une structure
d'oignon cylindrique.
Il a en gros la forme d'un cylindre
enveloppant le point de collision.
Quand des particules sont produites
lors de la collision,
elles traversent différentes couches
de capteurs
ayant chacune une fonction bien précise.
Au cœur du cylindre, là où se produit
la rencontre des deux faisceaux
et donc les collisions se trouvent
les trajectographes.
Il s'agit de minuscules capteurs arrangés
comme une matrice et qui permettent
d'identifier la position des particules
produites sans trop les perturber.
En quelque sorte c'est comme une caméra
à 50 millions de pixels
qui pourrait voir des particules
individuelles
tout en fonctionnant à 40 millions
d'images par seconde.
Ces trajectographes ne détectent
que les particules chargées
mais permettent de reconstituer
leur trajectoire
à quelques dizaines de microns près.
Grâce à un champ magnétique énorme
il est également possible
d'identifier certaines de leurs
caractéristiques
comme leur impulsion ou leur énergie.
Sur la deuxième couche de l'oignon on trouve
le calorimètre électromagnétique.
Un calorimètre c'est un appareil capable
d'intercepter certaines particules
et, en les absorbant,
de mesurer leur énergie.
Ce premier calorimètre est dit
électromagnétique
car il peut absorber les photons,
les positrons, et les électrons.
Comme nous le verrons plus tard,
il est essentiel de pouvoir réaliser
la mesure de l'énergie de ces particules
avec la meilleure précision possible.
Pour cela le calorimètre électromagnétique
de CMS utilise
des modules faits de cristaux scintillateurs
ultra purs en tungstate de plomb.
Il aura fallu cinq ans de R&D et 10 ans
de production
24 heures sur 24 pour produire l'ensemble
des 76 000 cristaux nécessaires à CMS.
Sur la couche suivante se trouve
le calorimètre à hadrons,
c'est un autre appareil dont la fonction
est de mesurer des énergies
mais cette fois pour les hadrons,
c'est-à-dire les protons, les neutrons
et les autres particules faites de quark.
La technique est différente de celle
des cristaux
et utilise un sandwich alterné de métaux
et de plastique scintillateurs.
Et enfin sur la couche la plus externe de CMS
se trouve le gros morceau,
les chambres à muons.
En effet parmi toutes les particules
que l'on souhaite détecter et analyser,
les muons sont celles qui interagissent
le moins avec la matière,
et donc vont voyager le plus loin du centre
de collision
sans être affectées par les premières
couches de détecteurs.
Pour pouvoir mesurer les caractéristiques
de ces muons
et notamment leur impulsion et leur énergie,
on utilise un champ magnétique
avec une structure bien particulière
en solénoïde,
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui donne son nom
à ce détecteur "Compact Muon Solenoid".
Il s'agit d'une énorme bobine de matériaux
supraconducteurs
mesurant 13 mètres de long et 7 mètres
de diamètre
et qui enveloppe une bonne partie
du détecteur,
elle produit un champ de 4 teslas en faisant
circuler un courant de 20 000 ampères.
En conclusion, grâce aux quatre couches
de détecteurs,
il est possible de repérer et caractériser
presque toutes les particules susceptibles
d'être produites lors d'une collision,
à l'exception des neutrinos qui ne sont
captés par aucun détecteur
mais dont on peut deviner la présence
indirectement, par un bilan d'énergie.
Au total pour mettre au point
un détecteur comme CMS,
il a fallu imaginer des technologies
de pointe
d'une fiabilité et d'une résistance
à toute épreuve.
En effet avec presque 1 milliard
de collisions par seconde,
les dizaines de milliers
de circuits intégrés
qui composent l'électronique
de ce détecteur
sont soumis en permanence à d'intenses
radiations,
et pourtant ils doivent préserver
une fiabilité exceptionnelle
tout en fonctionnant à une fréquence extrême
puisque un croisement se produit
toutes les 25 nanosecondes.
Sans compter qu'il est évidemment très
difficile d'ouvrir un tel détecteur
pour remplacer un composant défectueux
qui serait tombé en panne.
Nous voici maintenant à l'étape suivante
de notre visite
dans le centre de calcul du CERN.
Il s'agit d'une pièce essentielle
du dispositif puisque, on l'a dit,
les collisions se produisent à un rythme
effréné
et seule une fraction infime d'entre elles
est susceptible de produire un boson de Higgs.
Quand un boson de Higgs est créé et
se désintègre presque immédiatement,
il peut le faire de plusieurs façons
différentes,
par exemple en un quark
et un anti-quark bottom,
c'est le mode de désintégration
le plus fréquent, presque 60% des cas,
ou encore en 2 bosons w,
2 gluons, 2 photons etc.
Ce sont ce qu'on appelle les canaux
de désintégration.
La difficulté c'est qu'à part
le boson de Higgs,
il existe tout un tas d'autres phénomènes
susceptibles de produire
exactement les mêmes désintégrations
et donc de conduire au même type
de signal dans les détecteurs.
Pour avoir la confirmation
de l'existence du boson
on va donc devoir rechercher des anomalies
statistiques,
c'est-à-dire par exemple: un excès
de désintégration d'un certain type
par rapport à ce qu'on attendrait
si le boson de Higgs n'existait pas.
Prenons un exemple:
le cas où un boson de Higgs se désintègre
en une paire de photons.
Cette courbe symbolise en fonction
de l'énergie mesurée
la quantité de paires de photons
qu'on est censé observer en l'absence
de boson de Higgs,
juste du fait de tous les autres phénomènes
qui se produisent dans les collisions,
on appelle cela le background.
Maintenant imaginons que
le boson de Higgs existe
et que sa masse soit disons
de 130 GeV,
alors le fait qu'il se désintègre parfois
en une paire de photons
devrait se traduire par une petite bosse
ici vers 130 GeV.
Ça c'est pour la désintégration
en deux photons,
mais, on l'a dit, il existe plein d'autres
canaux de désintégration
dans lesquels rechercher ce type de signal,
et pour débusquer le boson de Higgs,
tous les canaux ne se valent pas,
l'idéal ce sont les canaux où la taille
de la bosse soit suffisamment importante
par rapport au background.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le rapport
signal sur bruit,
ce rapport dépend bien sûr de la fréquence
des désintégrations
mais aussi de la capacité des détecteurs
à reconstruire les trajectoires
et mesurer les énergies
avec une bonne précision.
Au total, parmi tous les canaux
de désintégration possibles,
les chercheurs de CMS et Atlas
ont d'abord concentré
leurs efforts sur deux en particulier.
Celui de la désintégration en deux photons,
dont on a déjà parlé,
et dont la bosse devrait être assez visible
bien qu'ils correspondent
à un phénomène assez rare,
un boson de Higgs ne se désintégrera
de cette façon qu'une fois sur 500.
L'autre canal qui intéresse beaucoup
les chercheurs
est celui qu'on surnomme le "canal en or",
il s'agit de la désintégration
en deux bosons Z
qui se désintègrent ensuite eux-mêmes
en deux paires de leptons.
Les leptons ici ce sont des muons,
des électrons, ou leurs anti-particules,
c'est un phénomène encore plus rare,
il se produit une fois sur 10 000,
mais il est assez spécifique
du boson de Higgs
et donc le background devrait être faible,
cela devrait se traduire par une bosse
bien visible dans les courbes.
Ça c'était pour la théorie mais une
des difficultés majeures
dans cette traque du boson de Higgs
c'est la quantité astronomique de données
qu'il va falloir traiter.
On l'a dit, il y à 30 millions
de croisements par seconde
et à chaque croisement ce sont
en moyenne 20 collisions
et des centaines de particules
qui peuvent être produites et captées
par les différents systèmes
d'un détecteur comme CMS.
Si on prend en compte toutes les données
produites par toutes les parties du détecteur,
cela représente environ 1000 téraoctets
de données par seconde,
donc de quoi remplir mille disques durs
environ, à chaque seconde.
Il est évidemment impossible de stocker
et d'analyser une telle quantité de données,
il faut donc trouver un moyen de réduire
la collecte.
Pour cela, à chaque croisement, donc
30 millions de fois par seconde,
des équipements électroniques spécifiques
appelés "trigger",
effectuent des analyses préliminaires
pour déterminer si cela vaut le coup
de conserver les données correspondantes,
si elles peuvent conduire ou pas,
à la détection d'un boson de Higgs.
Ce tri s'effectue en 3 microsecondes
en essayant de repérer des signaux
intéressants
et permet de ne conserver les données
que d'un croisement sur 40 000,
ce qui en stockage est évidemment
beaucoup plus gérable.
Ces données sont alors sauvegardées
et réparties sur 140 centres de calcul,
situés partout dans le monde, qui procéderont
à l'analyse des signaux.
Comme vous vous en doutez,
je passe encore sous silence
énormément de prouesses techniques
liées au fonctionnement des détecteurs
et à l'analyse des données.
Car il est temps maintenant de parler
de ce qui a été annoncé ici,
dans le grand auditorium du CERN,
le 4 juillet 2012.
L'image que vous voyez maintenant
a été montrée le jour de l'annonce
par le porte parole de la collaboration CMS.
[Voix off] - "And when you do that,
this is what you see,
so that's fearly significant."
– Ce graphique concerne la désintégration
en deux photons
et représente le nombre de paires de photons
détectées en fonction de leur énergie,
en noir ce sont les données mesurées par CMS,
et en pointillé rouge
c'est le background c'est-à-dire
le calcul théorique
de ce qu'on attendrait en l'absence
de boson de Higgs.
Comme vous le constatez on observe
une petite bosse autour de 125 GeV
ce qui est un signe qui trahit la présence
d'une particule nouvelle ayant cette masse.
Comme je l'ai mentionné deux expériences
en parallèle avaient comme mission
de détecter le fameux boson.
CMS et Atlas, deux détecteurs fonctionnant
indépendamment
et selon des principes de conception
différents.
Un peu plus tard lors de la conférence
la porte parole de la collaboration Atlas
a montré le graphique correspondant
pour ce détecteur.
On y voit le même type de bosse
dans la même gamme d'énergie,
la courbe située juste en dessous représente
l'excès par rapport au background.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, on ne parle pas
d'une quantité énorme,
u total ce sont seulement quelques centaines
de photons en trop
qui ont été trouvés dans ces intervalles
d'énergie.
On comprend d'ailleurs la nécessité
d'être capable d'estimer
avec une très bonne résolution
l'énergie des photons,
si la résolution avait été moins bonne,
la bosse aurait été complètement étalée
et on n'aurait rien pu conclure.
Intuitivement on pourrait penser
que ces deux résultats concordants
de deux expériences indépendantes
seraient suffisants
pour annoncer la découverte
du boson de Higgs.
Mais non car les physiciens des particules
ont des critères statistiques très exigeants
et pour être autorisé à annoncer
une telle découverte,
il faut un niveau de preuve
encore plus élevé.
Heureusement les deux expériences Atlas
et CMS ont pu regarder
l'autre canal de désintégration
dont on a parlé,
celui où un boson de Higgs se désintègre
en 2 bosons Z puis 4 leptons,
le fameux canal en or, un canal très sensible
mais correspondant à des désintégrations
très rares.
Voici le graphique correspondant pour CMS:
on voit ici le background en bleu,
en points noirs les données mesurées,
et en rouge ce qu'on attendrait
de la présence d'un boson de Higgs
dans la zone des 125 GeV.
La bosse est bien là mais
comme vous le voyez,
cela ne correspond qu'à un très petit nombre
d'événements excédentaires,
moins d'une dizaine.
Et voici la courbe équivalente pour Atlas.
Au total, en combinant les deux canaux,
les physiciens
des expériences Atlas et CMS ont pu atteindre
le seuil statistique
au delà duquel on est autorisé à annoncer
la découverte d'une nouvelle particule.
Depuis on a beaucoup affiné les résultats,
en effet bien plus de collisions
ont été enregistrées
c'est une mesure qu'on appelle
la luminosité intégrée
et les résultats ont été bien évidemment
confirmés,
comme on le voit sur cette courbe
où les barres d'erreurs sont
bien plus faibles
et la bosse beaucoup plus nette.
À ce stade on pourrait se dire
que les résultats des collaborations
Atlas et CMS montrent seulement l'existence
d'une nouvelle particule
mais s'agit-il bien du boson de Higgs?
Eh bien il faut savoir qu'on a pu vérifier
aussi que les pourcentages
des différents modes de désintégration
collaient parfaitement
avec ce qu'on attendait du boson de Higgs
en plus de la confirmation du fait qu'il ait,
comme prévu, un spin égal à zéro.
Comme vous le savez certainement, suite à
la découverte du boson de Higgs en 2012,
le prix Nobel de physique 2013 a été attribué
à Peter Higgs et François Englert,
deux des théoriciens qui, il y à 50 ans,
avaient imaginé dans leurs calculs
l'existence du boson.
Le compatriote et coauteur
de François Englert,
Robert Brout étant malheureusement décédé
en mai 2011
sans avoir pu vivre la découverte.
Quand on voit tout le travail accompli ici
on se dit que le prix aurait aussi pu aller
aux physiciens
qui ont réalisé ces formidables expériences,
mais par tradition le prix Nobel de physique
n'est attribué qu'à des individus
et pas à des groupes et il aurait été
difficile de ne distinguer
que quelques personnes parmi les milliers
de scientifiques ayant collaboré
sur près de trois décennies pour rendre
cet exploit possible.
Aujourd'hui si nous avons pu faire
cette visite exceptionnelle au CERN
c'est parce que le LHC est
en arrêt temporaire
pour réaliser des opérations de maintenance
et d'amélioration.
J'ai donc voulu interroger
les physiciens du CERN
pour en savoir plus sur ce qui se prépare.
– Alors oui, effectivement ça fait
plusieurs années
qu'on a découvert le boson de Higgs
mais il y a encore beaucoup de mesures,
beaucoup d'études et analyses
pour bien comprendre les propriétés
du boson de Higgs.
Mieux on connaît les couplages de higgs,
les différents couplages,
mieux on peut comprendre les propriétés
des particules,
être sûr que c'est vraiment le boson de Higgs
tel qu'on le pense.
– On cherche parfois des événements
qui sont très rares
et donc plus on a de données plus on a
la possibilité de voir quelque chose.
Les "upgrades" ça consiste surtout
à augmenter
le nombre de collisions dans le LHC,
par un facteur 10,
donc cà veut dire qu'au point de collision,
on doit augmenter la densité du faisceau.
– Dans le LHC on a des aimants
qui font 8 teslas, en général.
On veut augmenter ce champ magnétique,
dans l'année prochaine
on va installer des aimants qui font
11 teslas par rapport à 8 teslas.
Donc pour faire ça, il faut augmenter
le courant,
donc pour ça on utilise typiquement
des nouveaux types,
de nouvelle générations de matériaux.
donc par rapport au niobium-titane
on va utiliser le niobium-étain
et dans quelques… dans environ 5 ans,
on va installer des aimants
qui font un "focus" beaucoup plus fort
pour mieux concentrer les particules
et pour pouvoir avoir plus de luminosité
donc plus de collisions entre particules.
– Actuellement LHC a été conçu pour
une luminosité de 1x10 puissance 34
et la luminosité pic pour HL-LHC
(High Luminosity-LHC) sera 2x10 puissance 35.
– Une grande luminosité voudrait dire
plus de statistiques plus de d'événements
donc avoir plus de statistiques,
plus de luminosité peut être très utile.
– Par contre si on travaille sur
cette luminosité pic,
ça veut dire qu'il y a beaucoup de traces
dans les expériences
et les expériences arrivent mieux
à distinguer les différentes
origines de ces traces,
pour les détecteurs ça devient beaucoup
plus difficile dans ces cas-là.
– Donc vraiment dans l'idée du HL-LHC
on va avoir au lieu de 35,
on va dire, collisions par croisement
en moyenne,
là on va avoir à peu près 200
collisions par croisement.
Augmenter si vous voulez, le taux
de collision dans le détecteur
c'est quelque chose dont on a besoin
pour chercher des phénomènes rares,
sauf qu'ensuite il faut quand même être
capable d'y voir clair
dans la production de milliers
de particules en même temps.
On avait besoin d'avoir un détecteur
beaucoup plus segmenté
pour pouvoir être capable de mesurer
l'énergie des particules séparément.
Donc à l'avant on est en train de concevoir
cette fois-ci un calorimètre
complètement innovant.
Il s'agit donc de faire un détecteur
hautement granulaire,
ce qu'on appelle un calorimètre imageur,
qui est à la fois en fait la combinaison
d'un détecteur de trace,
d'un trajectographe et d'un calorimètre.
Là, dans ce cas-là, on va justement
segmenter donc
en ayant des parties d'absorbeurs
et des parties actives,
c'est qu'on va être capable de séparer
les particules entre elles,
donc vraiment être capable
de suivre
le parcours de la particule
et son dépôt d'énergie.
Donc c'est quand même un projet
très innovant
et aussi extrêmement compliqué à réaliser
parce que,
imaginez qu'un calorimètre aujourd'hui,
comme le calorimètre de CMS,
on a 75 848 cristaux de tungstate de plomb,
là le HG-Cal qui est le
"High-Granularity Calorimeter"
qui se retrouve à l'avant du détecteur
seulement, on parle de 6 millions de canaux.
– Il faut voir qu'avec la montée
du LHC en puissance,
on est obligé de faire des calculs
plus poussés
pour être capable de rejeter beaucoup
plus de bruit de fond qu'avant.
Donc cet objet il est développé
par les ingénieurs électroniciens
qui travaillent sur les expériences LHC
et c'est une nouvelle génération de systèmes
de déclenchement
dont le but va être de séparer de manière
plus efficace
les électrons et les photons par rapport
au bruit de fond.
Et donc là, on devrait gagner un facteur
2 à 3 sur la réjection du bruit de fond,
et ça c'est crucial pour qu'on puisse
bénéficier
des nouvelles données qui arriveront du LHC.
– Le boson de Higgs qu'on a découvert donc
c'est une particule,
mais il y a des modèles qui prédisent
qu'on peut avoir plusieurs types
de bosons de Higgs.
Si je prends l'exemple de supersymétrie,
on va avoir cinq bosons de Higgs,
trois bosons de Higgs neutres et deux
bosons de Higgs qui sont chargés,
et le boson de Higgs qu'on a découvert
serait le boson, le plus léger.
– D'accord, le plus léger des trois neutres.
– Il y a aussi des recherches qui peuvent
nous permettre de voir éventuellement
les particules qui sont les candidates
pour la matière noire elle même.
Donc en supersymétrie il y aurait
une particule neutre
qui interagit très très faiblement,
qui peut être une bonne candidate
pour la matière noire.
Et cette particule pourrait être générée
en même temps que d'autres particules au LHC,
et ça peut être à la portée justement
du nouveau rang du LHC.
Dans l'expérience LHC-b il y à des déviations
qui sont déjà observées avec les prédictions
du modèle standard
et justement, il n'y a pas assez
de statistiques pour l'instant
pour pouvoir confirmer ces déviations-là,
si c'est vraiment des signaux
de nouvelle physique ou pas,
et il y a beaucoup d'espoir qu'avec
le nouveau rang de LHC
on va avoir suffisamment de données
pour enfin bien comprendre
est-ce qu'on a découvert quelque chose
de nouveau
ou est-ce qu'il y a d'autres raisons
à ces déviations?
– Et en plus, dans le futur on peut aussi
augmenter, si on change les dipôles,
on peut augmenter aussi l'énergie
dans les particules
pour la même circonférence du LHC
ou si on augmente aussi la circonférence,
de 27 à 100 km par exemple, on peut bien
augmenter l'énergie des particules
pour avoir des collisions qui sont
très intéressantes.
Maintenant on est autour de 13 à 14 TeV
et là on peut augmenter peut-être
vers une centaine de TeV.
– Un des principaux espoirs des physiciens
aujourd'hui
c'est donc que le LHC finisse par nous
révéler quelque chose d'inattendu,
des phénomènes nouveaux qu'on
ne comprendrait pas
et qui nous permettraient d'aller plus loin.
En effet il reste toujours aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de questions ouvertes
en physique fondamentale.
Qu'est ce que la matière noire?
Pourquoi y a t-il plus de matière
que d'antimatière?
Et surtout comment unifier la mécanique
quantique et la relativité générale?
Et des éléments de réponse à ces questions
pourraient donc surgir
des futures expériences qui seront menées
ici au LHC dans les années à venir
[Générique]
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -